This is about Clark I'm here for the Brooklyn public library our streets our
stories project. Today we're here at the diner library to interview some of the members of the diverse singers.
It is every nineteen two thousand and sixteen. And I'm here with Maggie. Don't go
and so thank you for joining us now you're welcome. Where were you
born I was born in Kristiansand Norway. It's a pretty big town and
I forget how many thousands of people
but I was born there and I lived there until I was three and a half and then my
father was already over here so my brother my mother myself we took a plane
I think with a propeller Icelandic plane I don't know how many hours it took like twenty four
hours I think me two steps one in Iceland and they be one in
Newfoundland and my aunt and uncle they had already they were living here they
were working for the new My uncle worked for the new each in the consulate.
So they met us at the airport and and then that yes
remark years old I moved to at that time it was called Bay Ridge Brooklyn now it's called Sunset Park.
And fifty first Street between seventh and eighth we lived there for ten years eight
years but and then we were to sixtieth Street.
So I lived in that whole area now money six
streets you know like Florida now in sixty years I've lived like
in
within they reach Sunset Park Dyker Heights on the border.
Yeah. So that's where I started F. with your father also from Scandinavia. Yeah.
My father was a region carpenter over here yeah.
And what did your mother do my mother when she first came over here
she. She and my aunt they took turns they because they had
all had kids so we took turns cleaning they cleaned some houses for people in the
neighborhood and so my aunts would go on some days and my cousin was the same age as me and she had an
older brother and I had an older brother so they they work it out so that the days when my
aunt was working my mother was on with the kids and vice
versa. I remember with my cousin and I. They was like. Well done the.
Net learns about Liberace because my cousin used to play the piano and
he was on the he was on the T.V. in the mornings I think. And one
memorable thing I remember it at my aunt's house when I stayed there with my
cousin fifty second Street and they were the super She was the super in this building I don't know
how many apartments. But. She was on the second floor and so I guess I was
about
to buy my cousin the same age five years old and in the back of the house it was fenced in
and there was a little yard and a big tree in the back and on the lower branch they had
a an old tire with their I don't know what was used to the for the rope
to swing so it was of the hand they swing recycling you know.
And so I remember my answer when it was time for lunch she brought
the bucket out from.
From the window from the second floor and she had a rope on it and she made like sandwiches and some kind
of drinks for us and. Some fruit or something sent it down
on that on the thing for us in that I thought that was so clever like at that time those that
stuck in my mind I said oh that's a creative. You know to so go and down and bring us a lunch you just like
to know out the window when the bucket was a little ring and brought it down.
So that's one of memorable moments that I recall but
then sadly they
moved to Maryland and. That's two years later after we had arrived
so that was sad because I was very close to my chest.
Yeah but Brooklyn. I was thinking to this project how it's changed so much in those
years because that Eighth
Avenue in Brooklyn now is considered Chinatown Little You have all of everything is Chinese
there when we came sixty years ago everything was new each and they're changed so much so
I was remembering all the different. The bakeries down there and
the there was like two big reason a deadly Olson's and
Paterson's and there was that sons of Norway which is I guess kind of like a new Egypt
version of an ice a Columbus you know but. Region sons of Norway
and where else was there was a bike and we can buy music
Viking store on fifty seventh and then my friend went to school with and six grades.
Our father had the Anderson fish store right across the street.
So when I look back now and then I did do a book on it a few years ago called that
scarce Boulevard left coast is left in the region stew and
so they that they referred to that a fabulous new we can still do
and so that was transformed so I'm wondering to myself that was
like maybe thirty years ago. This is started changing around.
I'm thinking to myself I wonder what that's going to be like another thirty or forty years from now.
But I don't know maybe it will stay Chinatown because it seems like.
Like Chinatown downtown Manhattan that a state like Chinatown for so maybe the
Chinese artists asked to like pack up and move away as the new regions and other nationalities were I
don't know but anyway I have a lot of good memories from then have new
and you see what else I wrote down I wrote
some I wrote down the names that I could remember of a new region stories on
a new I wrote down and I remember there was an eighteen page
on was forty eight to forty one street in Eighth Avenue and in the old dainty they said
that used the coffee beans just becoming a bag and they used to ground it for you right
there and they saw that like when you finish and they put it back in the bag.
It smelled so good I remember that a P. coffee but now it's only in the Gore
may places where they have the blessings they used to do that all the time a G.P. a
coffee and let's see the story of remember Fredrickson hog
and that was the meat store on a
new. And then they moved to Fifth Avenue eventually but then they change the name to Sussex
and handsome but that's yeah. Eventually every single from Asia have you to visit
them you. And now I think they still have a line up they still have a parade every year
that goes on thirty. And you. Seventy from a parade.
Reachin Constitution Day parade even of a
neighbor who can constituency smaller and
smaller it's still going on I don't have how much longer of us still the neighborhood
changes so there's still a little bit of No we
just left in the neighborhood but not too much. Sadly the Nordic Delic
deli closed last January January fifth two thousand and fifteen.
They were also left for thirty years that was the last of
the Norwegian source in trying to set the place to get like dinners to
go say at you know there's a.
You know everything has to change but it's sunset when you look back is it the business.
Everyone from the culture like kind of moved elsewhere
and or with ever. You
know what I actually see the Nordic
really well like that lobster. Left cares that I said they have
this like a stew that every like Usually that it started out with being like
leftovers you put it in but then at the end people bought you know specifically to make the leg scarce.
They have that and then they have this potato dumpling. That you could buy there and
then they
had the meatballs you know in the region balls or Swedish meatballs they call
them and. Oh they
had I don't know
every Christmas they used to make all these batches of knowledge and cookies at that store that people used to
come from all over
just to get them at the
holidays Hong Kong which was like an ice cream
cone you could fill it with something and be just have a plane.
So you get all that stuff there and you could buy stuff
from the chocolates you know from Norway
and and fish a fish cakes from Norway and whatever
like packaging a piece in soups and stuff like that ready made process from
knowing you could buy just the
store here. Your favorite childhood
activity here. Let's see.
I remember going to Sunset Park to school but I don't know if it was a favorite but
I do have a go when there is very crowded everybody gets a blast and whatever but
that was before
air conditioning you know really people didn't have it back then so I was just to go there and cool
off to Sunset Park the forty forty seventh Street in seventh
heaven.
Yeah they all I did take a picture of it. From the neighbor
used to love like when I was little I remember playing with horses like that real horses blast
sources any kind of horse or tending we were horses like used to put a rope around it you
know like a horse and so for some reason I think. There
was a guy
that came around I guess just to have your photo taken you know they used it. That was they got your mother
or whatever they said you want take picture on a horse so I guess it was popular because I don't know how much they charge at
that time the scholars I guess. You got your picture. And. And so
I think it was my first time on a horse I think I must be about five at that time and.
And I was remember. I think I've had I don't know what I think about it now I think is how it was the plied
by the guy who was there had the horse and all the family has you know I
think about it I probably got license from the Christmas
tree
in the cowboy hat.
But yeah that was and then
I I finally got to go I remember writing I was twelve I guess I was from
some seven years later my friend and
I went to take a bus and we went to Staten Island to float
like clothes like stables which is still there today I
think we took the bus from Brooklyn to
there although I guess they had some places in Brooklyn but I was that was and
that was an experience you've got to be got to gallop to try and walk you
know started up so that was an exciting twelve. Money made it on
a real horse. To go to school in the area.
Yes first started out first grade.
P.S. ninety four on fifty's street and fifty first Street in six seven you still there out.
Yeah I guess they're all still there then we moved my last year
or sixth grade we moved to.
From fifty three to sixty a street so then I went to P.S. one o five on fifty eighth
Street and Fort Hamilton Parkway for my sixth grade and they went to Pershing Junior
High School which is on forty ninth Street and ninth Devon you. And for Hamilton High School.
That I went to Hunter for a while for three years and I just left I couldn't
make up my mind but I want to do so I left after three years and then went back.
And then I worked in an office for.
I guess that thirty years
and now I'm
retires turn sixty five in a couple of months so.
Looking forward to get my half there I said to Brenda.
I have fare on the subway in buses that will be nice that's one of the advantages of getting a little
older
and yeah. Is there anything else or
ones for say
now. Oh yes when I first came over here my first slice of pizza.
My
cousin she was born here you know she went back to Norway since you know like the reversal.
But anyway so she was going to introduce me to
pizza fifty third Street and Fifth Avenue King's pizzeria which she lived on
fifty second Street near Fifth and that place is still there today and this is like in one
hundred fifty five fifty six. And so she started me off with she had the pizza
and she gave me the cross like that that
was broke me into that because we were used to that pizza you know in Norway. So
it didn't take me long before I liked it you know to this day I love that pizza so.
But it's funny that that place is still around after sixty years you know that King's pizzeria
Yeah yeah.
If you. Things are still there. All these places here that I've
mentioned. They've all closed down like the deer has the Atlantic restaurant.
People used to go that was like a great bargain.
They've got all this food and we did meatballs and potatoes and.
We called Asda stewing which was like to do the math.
He's got all this stuff and lingonberries for like the very little money that was
a lot of carpenters who were single they used to go there after work and eat
there and then they would go to the deer head pub right across the street and have some beers or whatever.
And that was like yeah yeah.
Yeah
the Biggles going to Navy in the neighborhood that kind of you know what's funny is my brother was back to
Norway and now they have a sense of Norway in Norway the Norway branch or the people
who left when they were young and then change that and they still like the membership part
of it so now they have members even though
it started originally for people who moved away from their country and
now they have it in one branch based in or a few branches based in Norway
all over the country in the United States as well. And then you lived in Brooklyn most
of your right. Yeah I mean I've gone back and visited in that way gone
back probably all had a couple of dozen times probably
But yeah I've always. I like I like Brooklyn I like New York I like.
I like that you don't have to have a car to get around here it's nice convenient to take the
bus or the subway or your feet you can walk here
which I found at one time in Staten Island you can't like out of the but one place I was going to
set
jock something that Marshawn just marched on the Tibetan place. I got off the bus and
then I had a walk up to the top of the hill and I was the road I said oh my gosh you know
the cars as it went by is that you really need a car here in Staten Island because it's
dangerous to get
up off the road you're at a luck. You know. So that's about it.
I left a photo if you wanted to because I had an extra one from the class we had last time of this the on the
floor thing and I
put some stuff some notes on the
back seat when I went.
Oh yeah I think I mentioned that my first time writing this my first time on
a horse and then I went like a few years later seven years later with my friend Nancy Moore
who lived at sixtieth Street with me.
We took the bus we felt very young adults you know took the bus I guess and he was always one of the first few
times going on our own I guess right now is be considered young
twelve to go up from Brooklyn just at night alone through it but at that time kind of a kind of normal.
And I said that they
read in the fifty's was known as the rich but then I think in the seventy's they
changed the perimeter because Before Sunset Park was just the actual park but
then it became a whole area and they broke a ridge up. Ben's made it look
further over towards their home.
So yeah that is my story.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah well tell us come.